ya les gens qui se rendent dans les
commerces le 26 décembre pour trouver
l'eau 20 du siècle et ceux qui achètent
sur internet
phénomène de plus en plus populaire donc
toute la marchandise va rentrer par là
l'entreprise québécoise sert la hoover
il y a deux mois un entrepôt de 18 mille
pieds carrés pour répondre à la demande
grandissante des ventes en ligne depuis
un an le double innovantes web
alors on est très content et
présentement ça représente à peu près de
18% du de la valeur totale des ventes de
l'entreprise ont que ça va très bien on
est bien heureux en ce 26 décembre à
l'occasion des soldes d'après noël
l'entreprise aura cinq fois plus de
colis expédiés au canada
ça ressemble à coup aujourd'hui le
nombre de paquets que vous allez faire
ses continuelles je les comprends mais
c'est continuer s'arrête pas quand j'ai
des achats en fait vraiment plus en
ligne
c'est plus facile en fait on a pas on
n'a pas besoin de se déplacer on peut
faire nos achats n'importe qu'un clash
en ligne est de plus en plus populaire
les produits locaux aussi surtout avec
ce qui se passe avec nos voisins du sud
là c'est sûr que les gens sont un petit
peu plus conscients des produits
canadiens québécois alors oui a fait
effectivement il ya une croissance
l'avant de ses produits une tendance que
confirme la propriétaire de cette
boutique de produits artisanaux
j'essaie surtout d'avoir des produits
québécois fait au québec on a des super
beau produit et j'en découvre à tous les
jours et c'est les clients qui me le
demander c'est moi qui les veut avoir sa
boutique le fait que maintenant marlène
elle est propre et être propriétaire ici
j'adore ça et j'essaie d'acheter
toujours les différents items des
produits de québec
et pourquoi ce important pour vous
d'acheter des produits québécois rté
pour supporter les le monde ici à longué
pieds à québec
c'est important pour moi cette année un
quart des canadiens prévoient profiter
des soldes d'après noël ici marie michel
lauzon radio-canada à montréal